[Music]
you look very well thank you you really
do thank you i appreciate it so do you
and as do you oh thank you yeah um got
that out of the way yeah exactly now
let's get down and what can we improve
yeah no uh i would say uh yeah i thank
you i mean i'm kind of uh it's probably
the hair right it's probably the hair
your hair looks good
i'm getting to a cone in height i
realize as i was walking out here i'm
i'm almost at that point where i could i
probably could get there if i were
actually there's enough i haven't washed
my hair in six weeks
yeah there you go that's disgusting
that's about you no it's not me i mean
first of all mine is very uh it's down a
little bit tonight it happens it's moody
but sometimes it's
yeah i can get like a nine inch lift up
here sometimes
who do you have to think of to get that
hell innuendo um
you're not supposed to shout innuendo
after you
make an innuendo you're just not
supposed to i haven't i have an innuendo
that's what she said innuendo there you
go
i find that that the the higher the hair
goes the the the uh the less likely
people are to look at your face and
therefore it does help with people
thinking you look good
you think that's true not you but i mean
me just in general
oh i thought you were talking about me
for a second why would i come on your
almost gonna be really sad
but i'm not
ridiculous
incredible power the uh do you ever do
when you're at home did you ever like
you you know bring it down at all like
what what what
you know what i mean or is it all or do
you wear like that all the time it's
well i don't wear it like this it's just
it's got a springy action but yeah i
could bring it down i suppose i could
pull it forward
[Applause]
this is a whole new show you should just
cut backwards between us
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is talking the weirdest the title
is boy was that a storm
oh
uh have you ever shaved your head i know
uh uh you know some of the young people
yeah i go out there i see some of the
interns that work here and the guys they
shave their head no one was doing that
in my day i tell you no no unless
they're in the military maybe i would uh
i have shaved my head well or i had
someone else shave it actually uh when i
played basketball in in college
community college
you know so you know you know sort of uh
anyway um we a bunch of us uh shaved our
heads and yeah i took like a uh you know
one of those razors and i just you know
cut it all off and had like a little you
know crappy goatee like that and and a
lot of acne and yeah i was just uh
nothing sounds fantastic yeah it was
really amazing you made it sound like i
got myself some of that acne there yeah
yeah it was pretty it was pretty great
taught me character
um yeah so i did that and i and there
are a lot of people and maybe again
maybe you have the same thing with with
having hair that like that i you know
either don't wash or put like you know
hair product in a lot of people coming
up to like touch and be like what's in
there also grabbing it to see if it's
you know a wig or something having a
shaved head i've never had more at that
point in my life girls like like like
rub my head a lot of people like love
those they rub your head yeah yeah they
love the sensation or i mean guys too
for that matter uh you know
in fact mostly guys mostly guys it was
mostly men it was mostly men not one
woman did it to you guys if you want me
to be honest you know it was all guys
and uh but yeah you know just a nice
little sensation to do that and uh i i
wish i had a photo of it uh if for no
other reason than to remind myself to
make sure i never do it again but
because i think it would be annoying if
people came up and were like hi a pal it
is especially with that voice yeah
that'd be awful i'd be like
get out of here mickey mouse you know
come out no i really want to rub your
head all right well hop up here and rub
it little guy yeah